.
>> Bret: YOU BET.
.>> Ben: GOOD EVENING AND WELCOE
TO "FOX NEWS PRIMETIME."
♪
>> Ben: SOMETHING FUNNY HAPPENED
IN THE SPRING OF 2020, WHILE THE
WORLD WAS TEETERING ON THE EDGE
OF COLLAPSE IN THE FACE OF THE
ONCOMING PANDEMIC A NEW NATION
BRIEFLY TRIED TO CONSTITUTE
ITSELF RIGHT HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES.
YOU PROBABLY NEVER HEARD OF IT.
BUT THE WESTERN STATES PAC IS A
SYSTEM WHAT AILS AMERICA AND
HARBINGER OF THINGS TO COME.
THE LAST TIME WE RAN INTO A
GROUP OF STATES CALLING
THEMSELVES A PACT WARSAW PACT.
RHYMES THE WESTERN STATES PACT
WAS A GROUP OF HARD LEFT
AUTOCRACIES SEEKING TO IMPOSE
THEIR WILPON THE UNITED STATES.
LEFT COAST DYSTOPIAS LED BY
CALIFORNIA, OREGON AND
WASHINGTON STATE COALESCED IN
APRIL 2020 TO LOOK SOMETHING
LIKE A REAL NATIONAL GOVERNMENT.
AND BRIEFLY ATTEMPTED TO RELATE
TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ON A
PIER TO PIER BASIS.
NOW, I DON'T WANT TO TAKE THE
WARSAW PACT ANALOGY TOO FAR.
AFTER ALL IN COMMUNIST WARSAW
YOU COULD STILL GET A CROWD OF
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS CHANTING
WE WANT GOD.
YOU WON'T BE SEEING THAT IN SAN
FRANCISCO OR PORTLAND ANY TIME
SOON.
APRIL OF 2020, THE PACT EXCEPTED
TWO NEW MEMBER STATES COLORADO
AND NEVADA.
AND IN MAY 202024 PACT SENT
CONGRESS A LETTER DEMANDING
$1 TRILLION FOR THEMSELVES.
THE LETTER EVEN HAD NICE
MINIMALIST LETTERHEAD EMBLAZENED
UPON IT A DESIGN TOUCH EASY TO
MISS IF YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA YOU
CAN EAS
IT EVEN HAS A WATER MARK.
>> Ben: THEN NEARLY AS SOON AS
IT BEGAN THE WESTERN STATES PACT
ABRUPTLY DISAPPEARED FROM PUBLIC
VIEW AS THE INSURRECTIONARY
SUMMER OF 2020 DAWNED
PROGRESSIVE ALET'S CHALLENGE TO
THE FEDERAL UNION SINCE 1861
WERE DIVERTED INTO A MORE MOSAIC
VIOLENCE IT VIOLENCE AND MAYHEM
IN THE STREETS.
THE PACT DISAPPEARED FROM PUBLIC
VIEW BUT DIDN'T DISAPPEAR.
IT'S STILL AROUND.
WESTERN STATES WORK GROUP IN THE
NEWS FROM TIME TO TIME THESE
DAYS.
COPS PLAYING AS THE FALL FOOD
AND DRUG ADMINISTRATION AND
ISSUING COVID VACCINE APPROVAL
HID BY ABSOLUTELY NO ONE.
THE WESTERN STATES' PACT WAS THE
MOST BRAZEN ATTACK TO FORM A
STATE CON FEDERATION IN 2020.
MID-ATLANTIC MULTI-STATE COUNCIL
ALL FLICKERED INTO FORMAL
EXISTENCE IN THOSE CROWDED
WEEKS.
IN FORMAL STATE COALESCED IN NEW
ENGLAND, NORTH PLAINS AND THE
D.C. METRO REGION.
WHAT'S IMPORTANT ABOUT THIS
WEIRD PHENOMENA.
WHY BOTHER TO REMEMBER A HANDFUL
OF STATES WHO BRIEFLY CHALLENGED
THE CONSTITUTIONAL ORDER UPON
THE FORMATION OF THE AMERICAN
COALITION MINNESOTA GOVERNOR TIM
WALLS A DEMOCRAT EXPLICITLY
CALLED IT A LOOSE ARTICLES OF
CONFEDERACY SCENARIO.
YOU WOULD THINK IT WOULD
GENERATE SOME NOTICE AND IT
DIDN'T.
THAT'S THE POINT.
WE DON'T REMEMBER AWFUL THIS
BECAUSE OF WHAT HAPPENED.
WE MUST REMEMBER IT BECAUSE OF
WHAT DIDN'T.
WE MUST REMEMBER IT BECAUSE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FACED WITH
EXISTENTIAL CHALLENGE DID
NOTHING.
DOING FOG IS WHAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DOES THESE DAYS.
NO, I DON'T MEAN IN THE USUAL
SENSE OF HARRY TRUMAN'S DO
NOTHING CONGRESS.
USUALLY WHEN PEOPLE COMPLAIN
THAT THE GOVERNMENT DOES
NOTHING, THEY JUST MEAN IT
DIDN'T DO WHAT THEY WANT.
I MEAN IT LITERALLY.
I MEAN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
INCREASINGLY CAN DO NOTHING STEP
BACK FROM WHATEVER ALLEGIANCE
BIAS YOU HAVE FOR A MOMENT AND
SEE THE SPECTACLE OF THE UNITED
STATES INCAPABLE OF EVERYTHING
BUT NOTHING.
IT'S A NEW THING IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
SO NEW IT JUST CREPT UP US ON IN
THE PAST FEW YEARS.
SO SHOCKING THAT MOST OF US
DON'T SEE IT BECAUSE WE CAN'T.
PATTERN RECOGNITION IS ONE OF
THOSE GIFTS OF MAN'S INTELLECT
BUT IT REQUIRES A PRIOR PATTERN
TO WORK.
NEVER REALLY SEEN THE GOVERNMENT
IN WASHINGTON, D.C. CAPABLE OF
NOTHING BEFORE.
AND, YET, HERE WE ARE.
THE LIST OF THINGS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SUDDENLY CANNOT DO IS
NEARLY A LIST OF THINGS
ABSOLUTELY EVERYONE, LEFT AND
RIGHT, DEMOCRAT AND REPUBLICAN,
EXPECTS A GOVERNMENT TO BE ABLE
TO DO.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CANNOT
WIN A WAR.
SECURE ITS OWN SEAT OF
GOVERNANCE.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CANNOT
ENSURE DOMESTIC TRANQUILITIES.
GUARANTEE LAW.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CANNOT
ESTABLISH JUSTICE.
PROVIDE FOR THE COMMON
PROSPERITY.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CANNOT
SECURE ITS OWN ELECTIONS.
PROVIDE FOR THE COMMON DEFENSE.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CANNOT
SECURE THE BLESSINGS OF LIBERTY.
SECURE ITS OWN BORDERS.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CANNOT
PRIORITIZE ITS OWN CITIZENRY.
HANDLE A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS
WITH ANY COMPETENCE.
THE FALL GOVERNMENT CANNOT
REFLECT AND ADVANCE THE VALUES
OF ITS OWN PEOPLE.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CANNOT
ASSERT IT ONLY CONSTITUTIONAL
AUTHORITY VERSUS AN UPSTART
LETTERHEAD BEARING PACT.
WHAT COUNTY FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
DO?
TRY NOT PAYING YOUR TAXES OR
PROTESTING AN OUT-OF-CONTROL
SCHOOL BOARD OR SENDING A JOKE
TWEET AND YOU WILL FIND OUT.
THEY WILL TRY, THEY WILL PUT
EVERY EFFORT INTO TRYING TO
CRUSH YOU LIKE A BUG.
IT'S A LATE SOVIET STATE OF
AFFAIRS.
WE LIKE TO THINK THAT THE USSR
FELL BECAUSE PEOPLE'S YEARN FOR
FREEDOM.
THE SOVIET EMPIRE ACTUALLY
COLLAPSED BECAUSE IN THE END ITS
GOVERNMENT COULD DO NOTHING.
COME THE EARLY 1990s THE
AVERAGE SOVIET CITIZEN LIVED IN
A COUNTRY DEFEATED IN AVERAGE,
SHOT THROUGH WITH ENDEMIC
VIOLENCE, STRICKEN WITH
RADICALLY EMPTY GROCERY SHELVES,
INCREASINGLY WORTHLESS CURRENCY
AND RULED BY AN AGING GROUP OF
IDIOTS WHOSE GOVERNANCE VEERED
BETWEEN INSANE RADICALISM AND
LETHAL INCOMPETENCE.
IT WAS A COUNTRY LIKE, WELL,
LIKE THE ONE YOU AND I LIVE IN
TODAY.
DO YOU REMEMBER THE NAME OF OUR
COUNTRY THOUGH?
IT'S THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
AND THAT'S THE KEY TO HOW WE
FIND A PATHWAY OUT OF THIS
PREDICAMENT.
IF THE SWAMP TICKS GROWN FAT AND
HAPPY OFF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WON'T DO THEIR JOBS, STATES MUST
STAND UP AND DO IT THEMSELVES.
IN ESSENCE, WHO AM I?
I'M THE GUY WHO DOES HIS JOB.
YOU MUST BE THE OTHER GUY.
TREAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
LIKE THE ANGRY OLD RELATIVE
SENDING ALL CAPS EMAILS.
YOU ONCE IMPOSED UNLAWFUL
MANDATES BY EMAIL.
DECIDE SCHOOL POLICIES WHERE YOU
HAVE NO AUTHORITY.
YOU WANT TO CONTROL OUR TRAVEL
AND BULLY OUR BUSINESSES AND
PRETEND THE TENTH AMENDMENT
DOESN'T EXIST?
I WON'T SAY THE FIRST PART OF
THE SENTENCE I'M THINKING
BECAUSE THIS IS A FAMILY PROGRAM
BUT IT ENDS WITH SUE ME.
IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE THAT WAY.
BUT THAT'S THE WAY IT IS.
THIS INCOMPETENT DECREPIT
FEDERAL BEHEMOTH WANTS TO IMPOSE
TOTAL CONTROL OVER HOW YOU LIVE,
INDOCTRINATE YOUR CHILDREN,
SNOOP ON TRANSACTIONS, MONITOR
YOUR OPINIONS FOR WRONG THINK
AND DISSEND WITH FULL MIGHT TO
RUIN YOU AS THEY SEE FIT.
AND THEY CAN'T EVEN KEEP TRACK
OF BORDER RUNNERS OR REFUGEES OR
TELL OUR FRIENDS FROM OUR FOES.
AUTHOR STEVE HAYWARD HAD A LINE
ABOUT JIMMY CARTER HE WROTE THAT
HE HAD RUN FOR OFFICE ON THE
PROMISE OF DELIVERING A
GOVERNMENT AS GOOD AS THE PEOPLE
ONLY TO DISCOVER THAT THE PEOPLE
WERE NO GOOD.
THAT SEEMS A LOT LIKE WHAT WE'RE
HEARING FROM THE WHITE HOUSE
TODAY.
BUT YOU KNOW THE TRUTH.
YOU KNOW WHO THE GOOD GUYS ARE
AND THE BAD GUYS FROM THIS
SITUATION.
SO THE QUESTION FOR YOU, FELLOW
CITIZEN OF WHAT WAS AND IS THE
GREATEST NATION IN THE HISTORY
OF THE WORLD, IS WHETHER YOU
WILL ACCEPT THIS REALITY AND
SURRENDER TO THESE INCOMPETENT
RADICALS OR BE WIDE AWAKE TO THE
FIGHT AHEAD.
I'M BEN D